[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pendant le confinement
toutes nos équipes se mobilise pour vous
faire vivre les travaux parlementaires
durant cette crise sanitaire du coroner
virus une crise d'ampleur internationale
c'est pourquoi les sénateurs ont
auditionné le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian
l'occasion de faire le point sur le rôle
de l'om est-ce l'organisation mondiale
de la santé qui est affaibli par les
états unis sur les relations tendues
entre la france et la chine durant cette
crise du corona virus et puis sur la
situation en afrique qui préoccupe
beaucoup la communauté internationale
l'audition de jean yves le drian s'est
tout de suite pour que le plus grand
nombre puisse parler dans le temps que
nous consacre le ministre et donc
puisqu'il est 16h30 hé bien je vais donc
ouvrir cette commission monsieur le
ministre
merci de nous consacrer ce temps et
voyez bien que c'est un grand plaisir
pour nous de vous retrouver nous savons
que vous aimez toujours vous adresser à
la commission et on a toujours beaucoup
de plaisir à vous entendre et dans cette
occasion un peu particulière je voudrais
au nom de mes collègues vous exprimer
notre reconnaissance la reconnaissance à
votre ministère et notre reconnaissance
à vous personnellement pour votre
engagement et votre action personnelle
notamment vis-à-vis de cet exploit qui a
consisté à faire entrer plus de cent
cinquante mille français en quelques
semaines nous avons maintenant combien
cela a été compliqué difficile et votre
engagement personnel sur ce dossier a
permis de régler bien des problèmes et
je voudrais parce qu'anna vous demander
de d'adresser à l'ensemble de nos
personnels diplomatiques qui malgré les
restrictions budgétaires malgré les
contraintes que nous connaissons bien
ont été formidables dans tous les pays
ont été à l'écouté de nos français
voyageurs et résidents et je voudrais
que vous la voulez vous assuriez de
notre soutien de notre reconnaissance de
notre amitié et croyez bien que lorsque
viendront les moments budgétaire nous
nourrit
on passe ce ce moment monsieur le
ministre nous étions convenus ensemble
de faire de cette commission une
présentation de l'état du monde qui
malheureusement ne s'arrange pas car on
a un peu l'impression que le coc vide
est une sorte d' accélérateur
géostratégique de toutes les menaces qui
était déjà bien nombreuses et qui sont
encore une fois à l'oeuvre
on a même l'impression que ce qu ville
de bordeaux un coup on n'espère pas
décisif au système multilatéral de
l'après guerre on vient de voir la nuit
dernière une décision bien dommageable
du président américain
suspendre ses versements la contribution
américaine à l' oms
l'union européenne veut nous en parlerai
donc on a vraiment tout à fait le désir
de vous entendre sur un ordre du jour
qui est un peu chargé c'est pour ça que
je vais vous donner la parole très vite
les principaux thèmes qui nous qui nous
occupe ici nous ce qui nous intéresse ce
sont évidemment l'action que vous avez
menées en faveur des français de
l'étranger on sait qu'une deuxième vague
se profile d'afrique
peut-être d'amérique latine si des
résidents français des résidents
français voyant la pandémie arriver
jusqu'à jusqu'à leur pays de résidence
souhaite revenir sur le continent
on a ce problème du retour des jeunes en
asie et tout laisse à penser que il
pourra y avoir là aussi des difficultés
j'ai par les difficultés européennes
vous nous direz comment vous avez quel
jugement vous portez sur la la
coordination que l'europe a mené men et
espère mener face à cette crise qui
déstabilise tous nos pays
et puis bien sûr un sujet sur lequel du
reste le président du sénat lui même
nous a demandé de de réfléchir c'est la
citation l'afrique nous sommes
évidemment très inquiets des
conséquences de la pandémie en afrique
soit sur le plan sanitaire le plan
économique social politique
d'immigration etc
et puis enfin si vous le souhaitez mais
je sais que vous le ferez nous aimerions
bien savoir quel est l'impact de cette
crise plus vite sur les grandes crises
de sécurité irie libre
irak liban ukraine on a vu encore dans
les dépêches récente qu en ukraine les
combats continuent comme si de rien
n'était tout ceci est dommageable pour
la paix du monde
voilà pourquoi votre audition est très
attendue elle est suivie par une partie
de la presse accréditée et nous allons
être très attentifs à vos propos avant
de céder la parole à aux représentants
de chapeau monsieur le ministre vous
avez d'abord vous m'entendez là parce
que monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
suis aussi très heureux d'avoir cette
relation avec vous dans une
configuration particulière à laquelle
nous sommes pas adapté mais on va
essayer de mener nos conversations et
nos échanges avec autant de qualités que
lors des auditions au sénat
et je pense très important que nous
puissions dans cette période difficile
pour tout le monde garder ce lien
d'échangé de compréhension mutuelle sur
l'ensemble des enjeux
je voudrais surtout dans mon propos des
paf parlé de quatre sujets d'abord la
situation de des français à l'étranger
des français de l'étranger
la distinction n'est pas secondaire je
vais y revenir vous parlez de la réponse
européenne vous de meyer et inciter
monsieur le président vous parler de la
situation africaine et puis de d'évoquer
sans doute très rapidement dans un
premier temps les différentes crises qui
se maintiennent malheureusement les
situations de conflits tu alité ne ne
s'arrête pas avec eux le coronavirus et
ensuite je serai heureux de pouvoir
échanger avec vous sur ce sujet ou sur
tout en fonction de vos de vos intérêts
d'avoir d'abord sur renom ressortissants
à l'étranger de l'étranger je distingue
les deux parce que dans un premier temps
il nous à cet enjeu
faire en sorte que nos compatriotes qui
étaient en déplacement soit pour des
raisons personnelles soit pour des
raisons de tourisme soit pour des
raisons d'affaires puisse retrouver le
territoire national dans la mesure où
par ailleurs comme vous le savez le
trafic aérien mondial se limite est de
plus en plus c'est de plus en plus
limités aujourd'hui et que par ailleurs
beaucoup de pays fermé leurs frontières
non seulement fermer leurs frontières
des fermes et aussi leur arrivée à leur
aéroport et non seulement fermer les
aéroports les femmes aient aussi leur
espace aérien et dans leurs relations
aériennes intérieures tous à entraîner
des situations parfois extrêmement
extrêmement difficile et nous avons pu
faire en sorte que ces présidences 166
mille sa date d'hier soir de nos
compatriotes aient pu rentrer venant de
140 pays différents et chaque pays
chaque situation était une situation
compliquée où il fallait soit affrété
des vols soit téléphoné au ministre des
transports ou mais les affaires
étrangères voit même au président de la
république parfois pour permettre que ce
flux puisse revenir je pense que nous
sommes maintenant à peu près à la fin de
cette de cette étape même si il risque
d'y avoir encore quelques complications
sur les ce que vous avez cité le
programme vacances travail c'est sûr les
jeunes français qui sont nombreux en 30
en australie en nouvelle zélande au
canada au canada ne pas trop de demandes
mais en australie en nouvelle zélande
oui parce qu'en raison du confinement
général dans ces pays
ils sont ils rencontrent des difficultés
puisque certains d'entre eux étaient
travailler dans des activités
d'hôtellerie de tourisme et se retrouve
parfois sans emploi sans activité avec
les difficultés sociales qui s'en
suivent et nous les avons invités à se
manifester auprès de nos consulats et
nous avons mis en place sur l'australie
et sur la nouvelle zélande
des vols à tarifs tu soit suffisamment
attractif pour eux pour permettre à ceux
qui le veulent de rentrer en france et
cela nous allons poursuivre parce que ce
ne sera pas fini à la fin de cette
semaine
mais je dois dire que ce mouvement se
poursuit je pense que normalement ces
jeunes auxquels vous faites référence
ceux qui veulent rentrer c'est pas le
cas de tous pourront le faire dans les
meilleures conditions
ça a été une opération très compliquée
jeu elle a pu se dérouler grâce à la
bonne collaboration que nous avons eues
avec air france et avec eux les
compagnies filiales et en france avec la
coopération aussi d'autres compagnies
aériennes le pensent eux je les cite
parce que ils ont été tout à fait
déterminant je pense entre autres à
qatar airways mais aussi 4 sofiane
airlines avec qui nous avons eu des
relations très très suivi qui font que
l'on a pu aboutir à ce qu'il y ait ce
retour de 166 mille français et donc
l'année à partir de la semaine prochaine
aux fenêtres tout sur une nouvelle donne
dans la mesure où les compagnies
aériennes mondiales ont réduit
considérablement leur liaison qu'ils ont
constitué comme c'est le cas d'air
france
ce qu'on appelle un réseau squelette est
mal de nos nous ressortissants qui n'ont
pas pu ou pas voulu ou non pas su être
au rendez vous depuis depuis un mois
devront à ce moment-là prendre d'autres
dispositions pour rentrer par les vols
de parler vol classique tout cas je
voudrais vous remercier monsieur le
président du message que vous nous avez
adressé
je sais que lorsque jean baptiste
lemoyne a été reçu par la commission
vous l'avez également remercier je pense
que notre centre de crise ici et les
postes partout ont su faire face dans
des conditions qui étaient parfois
difficiles parce que les français sont
parfois impatients et reconnaissent le
service rendu souvent que en arrivant à
la maison mais en tout cas
c'était notre devoir est de remerciement
des dessins et des autres il a fallu
aller repêcher des jeunes en la
cordillère des andes ou dans des îles
des philippines
parfois c'était très compliqué parce
aussi aux îles fidji ou d'autres
d'autres lieux qui étaient assez assez
compliqué ça c'est le règlement
je pense aujourd'hui à peu près acte est
de retour des français qu'il était en
voyage
concernant les français résidant
expatriés qui sont là depuis tout le
temps pour certains ou qui sont là
depuis quelques années pour d'autres qui
ont une activité qui se sont implantées
notre conseil c'est qu'ils restent sur
place condition évidemment mais ça
s'impose de respecter les règles de
confinement qui sont édictées par les
autorités des différents pays où il se
trouve ils sont trois millions et demi
vous imaginez bien que à peu près 3
millions et nous leur conseillons
d'ailleurs de profiter de cette
situation un peu compliquée pour
s'inscrire sur le registre des français
à l'étranger ce que certains oublient de
faire ce qui fait qu'on a une estimation
de premier league même s'il ya un peu
plus de 2 millions d'inscrits sur le
registre nos estimations sont à peu près
de ce type est donc conseillons à ces
français à l'étranger de respecter les
normes
nous conseillons aussi à ces français à
l'étranger de se faire connaître s'ils
sont vulnérables s'ils ont des
fragilités personnel des fragilités
c'est différent en particulier est
généralement les postes les connaissent
dans ces cas là enfin encore faut-il
faire la démarche nécessaire et à la
demande du président de la république
nous nous travaillons en ce moment pour
mettre au point un dispositif de soutien
sanitaire donc une dimension de soutien
médical avec aussi une dimension
d'évacuation potentiel si le cas devait
se produire pour rassurer et c'est
évidemment cette ce dispositif va être
mis en place de manière différente selon
les pays
puisque le type de réponse et le type de
protection est différent mais chaque
pays vulnérables chaque pays sensibles
aura un dispositif adapté et nos
ambassadeurs vont communiquer aux
communautés de ces différents pays très
rapidement maintenant l'ensemble des
mesures susceptibles d'assurer de la
sécurité la protection de nos
concitoyens dans ces pays parce qu'on
peut comprendre qu'ils soient
interrogatif sur qu'est ce qui peut
m'arriver si d'aventuré il ya demain
j'ai un risque ou si je ne trouve pas de
médicaments tel ou tel médicament dont
j'ai besoin dans tout cela fait l'objet
d'une communication
chaque ambassadeur dans chaque pays
vulnérables dans les jours qui viennent
puisque nous avons quasiment achevé ce
dispositif aujourd'hui est que le
président de la république ce matin a
validé l'ensemble du plan c'est
important parce que il apporte que nous
puissions garder dans ses billes notre
influence et quand je dis sécurisation
sanitaires jeudi aussi sécurisation
éducative et sécurisation sociale parce
que on peut rester dans un pays où on
réside si l'enseignement se poursuit
dans le cadre de la ffe et des 522
établissements qui dépendent de l'
agence française pour l'enseignement à
l'étranger et nous avons d'ailleurs pu
apprécier je le dis ici parce qu'il faut
le dire que nous avons beaucoup apprécié
que le lait l'ensemble des enseignants
aient pu assurer la continuité
pédagogique soit resté sur place et se
soit engagé avec beaucoup de
professionnalisme et de loyauté à
l'égard de la communauté française est
aussi et des autres enfants qui sont
sous leur responsabilité parce qu'il
n'ya pas plus communauté française qui
fréquentent des établissements de la f1
heureusement il ya aussi une population
locale qui est tous assidus à notre
enseignement pas ça fait partie de
image la france aussi ça fait partie de
son influence donc nous sommes très
soucieux de la situation particulière de
notre système éducatif avec deux trois
aspects l'aspect des bourses
l'aspect de l'aide à certaines familles
c'est-à-dire une aide sociale propre à
des situations particulières ne
serait-ce que une famille donc
l'activité a diminué parce que il ya un
confinement dans tel ou tel pays et puis
surtout aussi en même temps le fait que
certains établissements en difficulté à
tenir parce que les charges restent là
et parce que la fréquentation c est
moindre et donc nous allons mettre en
place dans les jours qui viennent
à la demande du président de la
république appelant d'urgence pour
assurer un soutien massif à tout le
réseau pour depuis cet assuré dans la
continuité c'est une manière aussi de
répondre à la sécurisation de nos
concitoyens à l'étranger
voilà un ensemble sécurité sanitaire
sécurité éducatif sécurité sociale sur
les familles les plus en difficulté que
chargé de mettre en oeuvre et qui va
être mise en oeuvre dans les plus brefs
délais maintenant ce plan nécessitera
des traduction législative certaines de
ces options seront nécessaires à cet
égard y compris financière bien sûr mais
d'autres points
d'autres dons et nous aurons l'occasion
de rendre public que cet ensemble dans
les plus brefs délais maintenant puisque
la proximité de le règlement de
l'ensemble du plan est en train de
s'achever
donc dans les jours qui viennent cela
sera en du public
c'était le premier point que je voulais
soulevés qui est un point important que
cela concerne directement nos
compatriotes et je tenais à vous en
faire part devant la commission en
sachant que jean-baptiste lemoyne a déjà
eu l'occasion d'affrontements en parler
antérieur le deuxième point sur lequel
je voudrais revenir avec vous concerne
réponse européenne à la crise je
considère pour ma part que il ya eu un
peu de retard à l'allumage dans la
machinerie européenne la présidente de
la commission elle-même madame van der
laan l'a reconnu il ya eu un peu de
retard dans la solidarité pour
différentes raisons d'avoir parce que
l'épidémie surpris tout le monde dans
son ampleur s'est déclenchée en italie
mais l'ampleur en europe
coop désarçonné deuxièmement parce que
la santé n'était pas au coeur des
compétences et des vigilances de l'union
à ça fait partie aussi de deux des
traités et des compétences affirmées
mobilisés et puis aussi parce que dans
devant l'urgence les états a eu tendance
à réagir de manière dispersée au départ
mais ce premier retard à l'allumage à
mon avis a été largement rattrapé
d'abord parce que la solidarité concrète
européenne était au rendez vous je
reviens pas sur les gestes de posées par
l'allemagne la suisse le luxembourg
l'autriche pour accueillir nos
compatriotes hospitalisée mais elle
s'est fait aussi pour d'autres pays et
ensuite parce que nous avons pu
collaborer ensemble pour aider nos
ressortissants bloqués aux quatre coins
du monde à revenir grâce à un mécanisme
européen de protection civile qui a été
particulièrement efficace
ensuite parce que la solidarité concrète
s'est aussi manifestée par la
mobilisation de nos instruments d'appui
humanitaires et de développement tout
cela a permis une prise de conscience
collective mais surtout là je considère
que l'europe était au rendez vous de la
réponse et économique à la crise chacun
leur a constaté toutes les institutions
européennes capables de soutenir nos
économies sont au rendez vous la
commission la coque centrale européenne
la banque européenne d'investissement il
ya eu un premier une première série de
mesures qui est a été prise très tôt
avec des investissements et des
engagements proprement colossaux je
pense aux 750 milliards de rachats
d'actifs par la bce je pense aux 40
milliards de la banque européenne
d'investissement ou pense aussi à la
décision prise
de faire en sorte d'avoir des commandes
ob d'équipements et de protection tout
cela s'est engagé très vite dans un
deuxième temps et parallèlement à cela
le l'union européenne lever des tabous a
pris des décisions qui paraissaient
auparavant comme impossible voire
irresponsable je pense aux règles du
pacte de stabilité est aussi s'est
traduite rapidement par des actes par
des faits est là maintenant depuis
l'eurogroupe de la semaine dernière le
l'engagement européen sur 540 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires à la fois par la
banque européenne d'investissement par
la mobilisation du mécanisme européen de
stabilité et par l'initiative sur qui
permet de contribuer au financement des
chômages partiels mise en oeuvre dans
les systèmes nationaux
tout cela est un paquet significatif qui
s'ajoute aux autres et qui va être
complétée maintenant je suis maintenant
convaincu par la mise en place d'un plan
de relance d'un fonds de relance que la
france souhaitait qui a provoqué un
moment donné une confiture alité interne
d'un montant de nous évaluons à peu près
à 500 milliards d'euros qui permettra de
en mobilisant des instruments financiers
nouveaux de d'aider à la relance de
faire en sorte que les collectivement de
soyez en soyons à même d'engager
ensemble des désinvestissements pour
sortir de cette situation de crise une
fois que la pandémie aura été jugulée
donc là l'union européenne a été au
rendez vous malgré un temps de retard
je suis convaincu que le plan de réponse
globale va être validé au conseil des
chefs d'état du gouvernement qui va se
tenir le 23 avril
et je suis aussi convaincu que cette
deux épisodes et la suite va amener à ce
que l'europe s'interroge sur elle-même
pour être à la fois plus réactif
pragmatique
plus solidaires mais qu'elle soit aussi
plus souveraine dans danser dans ses
engagements et dans ses décisions
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire hier à
l'assemblée nationale et je le redis
devant le sénat aujourd'hui que je
considère que la crise peut être pour
l'europe un accélérateur de refondation
en tout cas leur pose des actes qu'elle
n'a jamais posé et n'a jamais peut-être
osé ni voulu poser mais ils sont ils
sont au rendez vous
3e troisième point excusez moi d'être un
petit peu long mais j'anticipe les
adhérents qu'aux j'anticipe un peu sur
vos peut-être sur vos questions mais je
pense qu'il faut que je dise tous les je
vous fasse connaître tous les éléments
qui sont en ma possession troisième
point l'afrique que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le président je vous dois dire
d'ailleurs en commençant eux j'ai été
j'ai entendu récemment des propos
extrêmement choquants moralement et
humainement scandaleux sur les supposés
expérimentation qui pourrait se faire en
afrique
déjà j'ai été condamné avec beaucoup de
fermeté
ça a été très largement relayée en
afrique le président de la république en
a fait 2 a fait de même ce matin sur
radio france internationale voudrait le
retard ici devant la commission du sénat
ceci étant en afrique
nous regardons la situation sans
catastrophisme sans prédictions
alarmistes mais avec une extrême
vigilance
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui et la pandémie
a été plus tardive que qu'en europe
qu'en france qu'en italie en espagne aux
états unis mais la vanne montrent même
s'il n'ya plus aujourd'hui que 816 morts
15 1249 qu'avant tout le continent
africain
il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui la quasi
totalité des pays sont touchés sa femme
deux pays sur 54
et que nous sommes qu'au début d'un
processus et on connaît la fragilité des
systèmes de santé africains une offre de
soins limitée des difficultés
d'approvisionnement pharmaceutique un
manque de ressources compris sur le
corps humain
et puis on sait aussi que en afrique la
stratégie du confinement risque
d'impacter très durement ceux qui vivent
au jour le jour de l'économie informe et
donc dans ces conditions notre devoir et
notre intérêt sont d'agir pour aider
l'afrique à faire face d'abord au nom de
la solidarité internationale ce sont nos
amis ce sont nos voisins on a avec
certains de ses pays d'afrique une
longue histoire
ensuite au nom de l'impératif sanitaire
parce que aider l'afrique aujourd'hui
s'est écarté la menace d'un effet
boomerang demain alors que nous serons
en phase de récupération
et puis aussi au monde est un impératif
sécuritaire parce que peut-être on y
reviendra dans les discussions les
terroristes ne sont pas confinés il
continue à frapper il ya eu des
événements récemment au niger au tchad
au sahel je le dirai tout à l'heure un
autre moment mais daraîche ailleurs dit
à ses membres de profiter de la
situation
2019 pour continuer à gérer même
augmenté ses des actions terroristes
donc il faut au nom de ces impératifs là
qui sont liées solidarité les faits le
risque de les faire autour l'impératif
sécuritaire qui n'apportent que nous
puissions continuer à travailler à aider
l'afrique et le faire de manière
exceptionnelle de manière très très
vigoureuse d'abord on est dans les
efforts africains
ce qui me frappe c'est qu'il y a eu une
vraie prise de conscience des autorités
africaines de l'enjeu est que les
autorités africaines ont pris des
mesures de grande ampleur en
anticipation et si on considère que le
chiffre aujourd'hui est relativement
faible c'est sans doute parce qu'il ya
la détection est moins importante en
afrique aia mais c'est aussi parce que
la pandémie n'est pas encore vraiment à
arriver on peut souhaiter qu'elle n'y
passe pas et ce serait tant mieux mais
je considère que les chefs d'état
africains se sont vraiment pour la plus
grande partie d'entre eux organisé j'ai
été aussi très très frappé par la
qualité du document dont vous avez
besoin d une connaissance maintenant ce
texte qui a été initiée par quatre le
président français mais relayée par
madame merkel par charles michel par le
président le premier par monsieur costa
par le premier ministre charles michel
par le ministre espagnol par le premier
ministre italien et par plus nombreux
chefs d'états africains et appelle au
sursaut pour la cré en développant des
propositions d'actions qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement forts qui nous
faudra essayer de mettre de mettre en
oeuvre tout cas ce texte de gaieté sorti
en 2010 est un texte fondateur d'une
relation nouvelle que l'on peut avoir
avec l'afrique donc soutenir les efforts
et puis accompagner les efforts à la
fois dans le domaine sanitaire avec des
besoins immenses ce qu'il faut renforcer
les systèmes de soins qu'il faut
renforcer les capacités de détection il
faut mener des actions de
sensibilisation est dans cet état
d'esprit
au niveau sanitaire la france a décidé
de réorienter
j'ai décidé puisque ça de ma compétence
de réorienter une partie substantielle
de notre aide au développement pour
l'accès sur les enjeux de santé les
enjeux alimentaires immédiatement avec
une affectation d'un milliard deux
affectés auparavant à autre chose pour
donner la priorité et l'efficacité sur
l'ensemble des enjeux sanitaires et et
humanitaires et des projets se mettent
déjà en place de façon très concrète
je note que leurs offres à prix aussi
des initiatives à cet égard et que
madame dhalla yann a annoncé une
mobilisation de 15 milliards pour les
pays les plus en difficulté dont les
pays d'afrique même si le compte n'y est
pas tout à fait pour l'afrique que
aujourd'hui mais nous allons travailler
activement pour que cela puisse être
mobilisée et enfin au niveau
al nous agissons avec eux l'om est
l'organisation mondiale de la santé avec
le fonds mondial de lutte contre le sida
pour que le multilatéralisme soit
vraiment ils présents et efficaces sur
le terrain et nous avons négocié un
accord particulier avec le fonds mondial
pour que 5 % de ce qui était donné au
fonds mondial puis celle de mobiliser
pour l'assistance technique puisque il y
a une trésorerie suffisante au fonds
mondial pour le faire afin que l'on
puisse bénéficier en particules du
réseau qu'offre le fonds mondial pour
être un relais d'intervention et de
compétence dans le domaine de la santé
secteur sanitaire secteurs scientifiques
africains puisque poussé l'émergence
d'un pôle africain en relation avec les
instituts pasteur d'une part mais aussi
d'autres outils qui permettront
d'accélérer la recherche sur le vaccin
en particulier et tout cela en lien avec
le gafi vous savez c'est un instrument
qui est une espèce d'alliance pour les
vaccins qui sera essentiel pour garantir
le vaccin quand il sera trouvée soit
disponible en afrique mais qui permet
aussi d'aider à l'innovation en sachant
que le font pour contre le sida lui
intervient surtout dans la recherche du
traitement et que le gars vie interne ya
plutôt sur les vaccins tout cela en
coordination autant que faire se peut
avec l'organisation mondiale de la santé
le troisième
la troisième priorité sur eux sur
l'afrique c'est l'urgence humanitaire
parce que le fait que les transports
soient beaucoup plus limités
qu'auparavant que les états aient fermé
leurs frontières abouti à des
difficultés dans ce domaine et nous
allons essayer de mettre en place au
niveau européen un véritable pont aérien
humanitaire pour transporter de l'aide
et nous travaillons activement avec nos
partenaires européens pour que cela
puisse se mettre en oeuvre
pidement en répondant à la mobilisation
lancé par le secrétaire général des
nations unies à cet égard et puis enfin
le quatrième pilier c'est le plan
économique
vous avez entendu comme moi l'appel et
les initiatives sur la dette qui ont été
initiées par les chefs d'état africains
et singulièrement leur ministre des
finances je veux dire que il y a une
bonne nouvelle c'est que sur ce sujet
hier soir une première étape a été
franchie c'est une première historique
puisque il ya eu un accord des
créanciers publics bilatéraux et des
créanciers privés bilatéraux pour un
premier moratoire de 20 milliards de
dollars à la fois au sein du club de
paris et aussi au sein du g20 qu'il va
se réunir ce soir pour valider
l'ensemble de cet accord et qui
permettra d'adapter cette cet engagement
le dire que c'est assez importante
puisque la chine qui était devenu ces
dernières années l'un des principaux
créanciers bilatéraux de l'afrique fait
partie de 2,7 de cet accord et c'est
sans doute de signer un acte historique
qui est qui est posée il faudra
maintenant élargir ce dispositif faire
en sorte que les institutions
multilatérales puisqu'il s'agit que de
la somme de d'accords bilatéraux puisse
répondre à la même logique pour que le
moratoire soit élargie et parallèlement
à cela
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république ne
organiseront pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une annulation des dettes pour les
pays qui pour lesquels cela s'avérera
nécessaire donc ce mouvement-là qui
paraissait impossible est en train de se
mettre en oeuvre comme d'ailleurs la
mobilisation par le fonds mondial de
droits de tirage spéciaux pour les pays
qui sont les plus en difficulté on me
signale la maintenant que ça y est à
cette heure le le g20 à kristen je vous
dis alors que c était négocié cette
mission maintenant c'est acté sur un
point de départ d'une nouvelle période
qui je l'espère sera suivi d'autres
d'autres engagements pour l'aller
les quatre enjeux africains sur lequel
si vous voulez en reviendra tout à
l'heure dans la discussion
alors vous avez souhaité monsieur le
président je le ferais très rapidement
que l'on fasse et un tour d'horizon de
la situation des crises rappelle que le
23 mars dernier le secrétaire général
des nations unies a lancé un appel au
cessez-le-feu mondiale rappelle que ne
pas de francs soit le jour de pâques a
tenu des propos lieder relativement
proche mais malheureusement malgré tous
les efforts diplomatiques pour la paix
et la stabilité
les crises se poursuivent dans la
violence en syrie dans le nord ouest
syrien et le réseau se dit libre
l'accord conclu entre la russie la
turquie le 5 mars dernier est toujours
en vigueur mais ni le régime syrien et
la russie n'ont pas renoncé à leur
volonté de reprendre le moment venu et
rien n'avance
au niveau diplomatique à genève donc ça
reste une véritable poudrière et même
une bombe sanitaire parce que la crise
humanitaire risque de tourner à la
catastrophe sanitaire à partir du moment
où l'épidémie ducobu 19 va commencer à
pénétrer cette zone où il ya deux
millions et demi de déplacés et nous
travaillons à ce qu' il puisse y avoir
des dérogations pour que l'aide
humanitaire et l'aide médicale puisse
arriver dans la zone dite libre sur la
libye cependant je serais tenté de dire
pendant la crise sanitaire les combats
continuent en libye il ya une trêve
décidée il ya trois semaines mais c'est
resté lettre morte et le processus qu'on
appelait le processus de berlin est un
peu encalminé parce que tu rêves n'est
pas respectée là une première trêve
l'internât puis une deuxième très ya
trois semaines mais depuis il ya des
offensifs qui ont et blanc sait pas
le gouvernement dit gouvernement
d'entente nationale avec un fort soutien
turc notamment sur la bande côtière qui
sépare très polie de la frontière
tunisienne et et puis le côtière qui
était jusqu'à présent tenu par le
maréchal haftar sont passés du côté de
du gouvernement d'entente nationale je
prends soin particulier à sabratha et
donc devant cette situation l'armée
nationale libyenne du maréchal afta a
répondu et donc nous sommes toujours en
situation conflictuelle les combats se
poursuivent malgré le corona ferries qui
n'a pas pénétré encore cette partie de
l'afrique mais ils n'apportent que nous
puissions essayer de faire en sorte que
les causes profondes de la crise vise
une cuisse est enfin mise en discussion
en négociation ça supposerait d'abord
que le remplaçant de monsieur ghassan
salamé soit désigné par le secrétaire
général des nations unies qui a du mal à
trouver un accord sur ce point ça
supposerait aussi que l'accord qu'ils
avaient de cessez le feu qui avait été
conclu après berlin puisse se mettre en
oeuvre ce qui suppose et le
démantèlement des milices et le départ
des mercenaires étrangers et cela
suppose enfin qu' on est un véritable
contrôle et une juste répartition des
ressources pétrolières et que l'embargo
sur les armes qui avaient décidé à
berlin soit soit respectée et à cet
égard
l'opération européenne guérini dont le
lancement avait été décidée il ya un
cyprès décidé à berlin le lancement il
ya quinze jours va se mettre en oeuvre
la france en sera le plus grand
contributeur
voilà pour pour la libye pour le yémen
il ya eu un appel après l'appel du
secrétaire général des nations unies un
cessez-le-feu a été annoncée vendredi
dernier par la coalition dans landry
vendredi à dix jours par
la coalition menée par l'arabie saoudite
pour une période initiale de semaine
malheureusement ce cessez le feu fait
pour l'instant l'objet de nombreuses
violations de part et d'autre il est
d'autant plus urgent de le mettre en
oeuvre sur le terrain que les premiers
cas des personnes atteintes du coc vite
19 sont apparus dans un pays déjà en
proie depuis des mois une terrible crise
humanitaire et sanitaire avait aussi une
épidémie de choléra et un système de
santé est dévasté nous soutenons les
efforts de monsieur griffiths qui est
chargé de faire reprendre les
pourparlers mais c'est parfois un peu
désespérant je veux surtout m'arrêter
sur eux deux derniers points en jeu par
l ukraine si vous voulez un peu plus
tard si dans la discussion c'est comme
souhaité mais je voudrais insister sur
l'irak et sur le liban pour conclure
l'irak fait face à une accumulation de
défis majeurs une crise sanitaire avec
eux l'épidémie de koffi 19 qui a
commencé qui a commencé à pénétrer le
pays il y à peu une crise économique
avec l'effondrement des prix du pétrole
dont le pays est très dépendant tensions
entre les etats-unis et l'iran qui se
détention se poursuivre sur le sol
irakien
au risque de l'escaladé puis une crise
interne
après des mois de manifestations et une
situation de vacance institutionnels il
ya maintenant après l'échec de monsieur
à la wii puis l'échec de monsieur orfi
nouvelles personnalités monsieur khademi
et qui a été désigné par le président
saleh pour former un gouvernement mais
on sait s'il va aboutir à la proposition
de ce gouvernement
et parallèlement à sa lutte contre d'âge
demeure notre priorité mais elle est
entravée par la situation politique
interne et par la situation régionale et
c'est d'autant plus urgent que cette
organisation terroriste tente de se
réorganiser sur le terrain il faut donc
faire preuve d'une grande vigilance
d'autant plus que je le disais tout à
l'heure
l'organisation continue à être très
actifs dans sa propagande et à diffuser
elle a diffusé le 31 mars un long
document appelant à la porte
d'actes terroristes pour profiter de la
crise du coc vie de 19
donc le risque terroriste reste comme
néanmoins une grande préoccupation pour
nous pour notre sécurité
dans notre situation politique
extrêmement instable un mort sur l'iran
sur le liban pendant où la crise
économique et politique que traverse le
pays depuis octobre dernier se trouve
désormais aggravée par la crise
sanitaire
j'entretiens régulièrement des
discussions avec eux mon homologue
libanais avec un message très clair au
delà des annonces qui ont été formulées
par le nouveau gouvernement diable que
les actes soient au rendez vous parce
que c'est indispensable pour redonner de
la confiance dans les autorités
libanaises mais aujourd'hui les actes
mettent du temps à se mettre en oeuvre
et ont bien peu dans le statu quo et les
réponses des réformes urgentes dans le
pays a besoin ne sont pas ne sont pas au
rendez vous dans un pays où le taux de
pauvreté est maintenant couvre plus de
la moitié de la population et dans le
volume sion économique est très très
préoccupante alors que en raison de la
crise du coc vide de les manifestations
ne se font plus discrètes à une vraie un
vrai sujet l'arrivée du coville devra
encore continuer à perturber la
situation au liban où vous voyez
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénatrices et
sénateurs
malgré la crise du profit de la
situation conflictuelle se poursuivre
l'ensemble de ces situations que je
viens d'évoquer rend urgent l'adoption
par le conseil de sécurité des nations
unies l'adoption d'une trêve humanitaire
tel que l'a demandé le secrétaire
général des nations unies afin
d'épargner les régions les plus fragiles
des effets de la pandémie et travaillons
de manière très étroite depuis quelques
semaines avec les membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité ce qu'on appelle le
p5 présent la république a pris beaucoup
d'initiatives et beaucoup de relations
avec les leaders du p5 peut-être qu'une
réunion des chefs d'états du p5 pourrait
se tenir bientôt en tout cas ne nous
espérons que les efforts mis en oeuvre
par l'ensemble par toute une série
d'acteurs permettront l'adoption d'une
résolution robuste du conseil de
sécurité qui fixerait les paramètres et
les conditions d'une trêve humanitaire
pendant toute la période de
développement de l'art de latran d'élite
je m'excuse d'avoir été un petit peu là
dessus le président et je voulais vous
faire pas de souci ça fait quand même un
moment qu'on ne sait pas lui donc je
pars fait pas le tour mais une partie du
tour des questions de billets voilà
évoqué dans ses droits merci monsieur
merci monsieur le ministre
pour toutes ces précisions je vais
maintenant donner la parole si vous le
voulez bien
l'ensemble des orateurs qui au nom des
groupes en demandant comme l'autre fois
chacun de condenser son propos de telle
sorte que la liste assez longue de mes
collègues qui souhaite aussi prendre la
parole dans la deuxième vague puisse le
faire dans le temps qui nous est imparti
et donc pour le groupe peur et les
républicains pascal oui monsieur le
président entendez monsieur oui oui je
vois pas qui me parle
pascal allizard oui monsieur le
président merci monsieur ministre merci
pour votre présence
j'irai directement qui est respectée
l'instruction du président et j'ai donc
trois points à évoquer avec vous c'est
minable et bien le premier point que
ministre pourriez-vous nous rappeler
l'été concernant le début de cette crise
du colis contenant les retours au quai
d'orsay de notre ambassade en chine fin
2019 et début 2000 20 et comment ces
informations ont elles été exploitées
toujours par rapport à ce niveau
international
vous l'avez dit dans vos propos les
appels à la solidarité existe mais
les luttes d'influencé vous l'avait dit
entre puissance aussi est le pays
d'origine de la pandémie et le pays
premier producteur mondial d'équipements
sanitaires deuxième donateur de l'aide
au développement mondial et créanciers
de beaucoup d'économie nationale alors
comment la france se situe-t-elle par
rapport aux autres pays européens et à
leur gestion de la pandémie et monsieur
le ministre vous avez convoqué
l'ambassadeur de chine en france hier
que ressort-il concrètement de cet
entretien deuxième point ce point porte
sur l'aide publique au développement et
et vous l'avez abordé c'était très
intéressant
le président de la république a évoqué
lundi l'annulation des dettes des pays
des plus pauvres quels pays seront
concernés
et quel en sera le coût pour l'agencé
française de développement par le passé
et là c'est dans l'actualité aussi
malheureusement l'aide française au
développement a participé à l'entretien
du sarcophage recouvrant un des
réacteurs de la centrale de tchernobyl
des incendies se rapproche
dangereusement de 700 drame avons nous
un bilan de l'utilisation de ces fonds
mais surtout quelle information crédible
avons-nous sur la situation sur place et
enfin sur l' oms
vous l'avez abordé aussi les usa
prétexte un manque de transparence à
retard d'information de l'institution du
fait de l'affluence chinoise et suspend
ainsi temporairement leur confiance du
ministre
notre représentation française vous at
elle informé de cette tendance entre
guillemets voilà une excuse peut-être de
l'aridité des questions mais pour être
concis j'ai évacué les phrases de
liaison merci beaucoup monsieur merci
merci pascal de cet effort méritoire
michel boutant pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre merci pour l'explication est
donnée en préambule je voudrais
concentrer mon intervention sur deux
points à savoir la france et l'europe et
la france reste du monde où le reste du
monde
nous sommes en quelque sorte à la
croisée des chemins en ce qui concerne
l'union l'union européenne comme l'a dit
l'un des premiers ministres de l'un des
pays du sud de l'europe où le virus
vient tabou de l'union européenne où
l'union
nous avons pu assister à une sorte de
valse hésitation où des pluies même à je
t'aime et moi non plus entre des pays du
nord de l'europe et du sud de l'europe
notamment à propos des corona bon ski
dont on a compris qu'il ne serait pas
adopté
en revanche 540 millions d'euros
milliards non d'euros a été adopté une
des questions que je sois vous poser
concerne la condamner la conditionnalité
donne accès à ce plan européen à ce plan
de relance
l'autre point particulier concernant
l'europe c'est que face à l'irruption du
virus dans nos dans nos pays nous avons
eu des comportements des réactions
vraiment nationale il n'y a pas eu sur
un plan sur un plan sanitaire de
d'unités d'actions
heureusement heureusement que face à la
menace et certains pays ont exprimé leur
solidarité
aujourd'hui où l'europe et solidaire
n'est pas simplement sur le plan
sanitaire même s'ils sont sur le plan
économique
ou alors elle connaîtra deux un avenir
bien sombre me semble-t-il est ce que
vous pouvez nous rassurer à ce sujet là
est entre autres sur vos lié à voler
pardon volet social sur qui vient en
aide
censé venir en aide au pays face à la
montée du chômage
ensuite par rapport au rapport au monde
mon collègue pascal allizard vient de
l'évoquer il ya d'évoquer votre
rencontre avec l'ambassadeur de la
république populaire de chine
hier matin je crois beaucoup d'entre
nous ont été maîtres des petites souris
pour savoir ce qu'elles puissent se dire
entre entre lui et mais cet activisme
chinois que l'on a que l'on a déjà connu
avant la crise
à nous donne l'impression de de
s'enflammer
un moment où nous envisageons cadre du
g20 de suspendre les les dettes de 76
pays dont 40 pays africains la chine
elle va continuer impunément à prêter de
l'argent aux africains est ce que d'un
côté il n'y a pas deux poids deux poids
deux mesures concernant le développement
de ces de ces pays on voit bien là aussi
une influence delà de la chine
est-ce que ça va modifier le modèle du
développement ou de l'aide au
développement de de l'europe
un dernier point sur la francophonie et
la situation de nos établissements
d'enseignement du français à l'étranger
dont la plupart d'entre eux où la quasi
totalité est fermé et qui malgré tout
continuent à demander le paiement des
frais de scolarité qui peuvent atteindre
des sommes extrêmement importantes à un
moment où les gens sont sont privés
d'emploi qu'est ce qu'ils en aient
qu'est ce qui est prévu pour permettre à
la fois le financement de ces de ces
établissements est laide éventuellement
apporter aux familles
merci mitel pour le groupe union
centriste olivier tadic
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre alors depuis mon domicile le
royaume uni en tant que français de
l'étranger
je veux tout d'abord commencé mon propos
par saluer votre action en qualité de
ministre et pour avoir accompli un
rapatriement d'une ampleur inédite
concernant le plan éducatif dont vous
nous avez parlé que vous venez de nous
annoncer
est-ce que cela prévoit un abondement au
budget des bourses pour le programme 151
est ce qu'un complément budgétaire est
prévu pour les écoles du réseau sur le
programme 185
je voudrais vous remercier donc au nom
du groupe union centriste d'avoir
convoqué officiellement l'ambassadeur de
chine à paris hier suite à des propos
inacceptables
le 20 janvier dernier ils avaient ils
avaient déjà comparé nos parlementaires
qui avait félicité la présence de la
présidente de taiwan pour sa réélection
à je cite des crapauds qui vous sautent
trait sur le pied ça ne mord pas mais
c'est dégoûtant
depuis ce week-end le site de
l'ambassade affiche les autorités
taïwanaises soutenue par plus de 80
parlementaires français dans une
déclaration cosignée ont même utilisé le
mot pour s'en prendre au directeur
de l' oms
je ne comprends toujours pas ce qui a pu
passer par la tête de tous ces élus
français elle cette fête news illustre
parfaitement ce que mon collègue rachel
mazuir et moi décrivons dans la note
intitulée des informations cyberattaques
cyber malveillance l'autre guerre du
comique 19 nous la remettrons d'ici
demain au président cambon une de nos
recommandations et de mettre en oeuvre
une force de réaction cyber afin de
répondre aux fausses informations dans
le domaine sanitaire et aux attaques
contre les valeurs démocratiques et pour
lutter contre les campagnes de
désinformation une influence de certains
acteurs étrangers comme la chine
pourriez vous nous indiquer si
l'ambassadeur de chine vous a présenté
des excuses
avez vous demandé à ce que ses propos
soient retirés du site de l'ambassade
car je les vois toujours en ligne l'afld
concernant le sanitaire la fermeture des
frontières européennes a lancé ce lundi
par le président de la république hausse
de nombreuses questions pour nos
compatriotes vivant à l'étranger qui
pour la moitié d'entre eux vivent en
dehors d'europe
de plus de 10 vols quotidiens entre
l'algérie et la france par exemple il ne
reste que deux vols hebdomadaires de
nouveaux compatriotes de nombreux
compatriotes souhaitent pouvoir rentrer
pour suivre des traitements lourds et
doivent demander l'intervention du
consulat pour accéder à un des rares
sièges d'avion disponibles il en va de
même pour l'approvisionnement en
médicaments
cela peut être fait exceptionnellement
mais les sollicitations sont massives
est ce que le plan sanitaire dont vous
nous avez parlé permettra la continuité
sanitaire envers nos compatriotes qui
doivent revenir en france pour être
soigné
je finis avec les étudiants veilleux
jeunes actifs qui sont amenés à rentrer
des etats unis ils sont souvent en
grandes difficultés financières car ils
doivent s'acquitter d'un loyer sans
pouvoir l'interrompt avant l'échéance
après une discussion avec plusieurs
bailleurs américain pour les français
cherchant à rompre leur contrat de
location pour rentrer en france
il est demandé aux locataires de fournir
un document consulaires attestons qui
lui est recommandé de rentrer en france
au vu de la situation économique et ou
sanitaire pourriez vous envisager de
mettre en ligne d'une telle attestation
qui faciliterait la rupture du contrat
de location sans préavis ni pénalité je
vous remercie
merci olivier je précise effectivement
que ce travail effectué par olivier
thiérache et les mesures sera en ligne
vraisemblement de demain en lecture mais
chaque membre de la commission leur à
demain sur son email
maintenant pour la république en marche
richard yong lee bonjour monsieur le
ministre bonjour monsieur le président
un ministre au nom de mon groupe est de
nous tous vous remercier pour tout le
travail que vous même votre secrétaire
d'état le centre de crise et le
ministère ont mené à bien ce
rapatriement formidable 160000 français
de l'étranger
je reprends les mêmes points que mon
collègue olivier cadic concernant le
système éducatif français à l'étranger
il doit être sauvé il doit être maintenu
avec cette difficulté que comme vous le
savez deux tiers des enfants scolarisés
sont des enfants étrangers et donc on a
un problème
en quelque sorte de mesure par rapport à
aux bourses aux efforts financiers qui
peut être fait mais sans ses enfants
étrangers il n'y a plus de système
scolaire français à l'étranger y compris
pour nos enfants
premier point l'appel du 23 mars du
secrétaire général de l'onu
un cessez-le-feu humanitaire mondial est
relayée par la france le président de la
république a déclaré ce matin qu'un
endossement formelle de cet appel par
les membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité était à portée de la main
mais qu'il manquait la russie est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus est
ce qu'il y a un espoir pour que les
russes finalement accepte ou vienne a
signé cet appel
est ce que c'est bien ce projet de
résolution qui est proposé par la france
et qui sert s'articule autour des deux
axes cessation des hostilités d'une part
et pause humanitaire de l'autre qui a
été validée par le président chinois
le président trump est le premier
ministre maurice cohn deuxième point
devant nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale vous aviez évoqué la réflexion
en cours menée par l'alliance pour le
multilatéralisme est proposé il faudrait
instituer une haute autorité mondiale de
la santé un peu comme le giec climat qui
serait une référence scientifique sur
les questions santé et qu'ils
travailleraient de concert avec le ms
bon malheureusement la crédibilité est
aujourd'hui largement entamé est ce que
nos autres partenaires ont accueilli
favorablement cette idée de création ce
que vous pensez pouvoir avancer dernière
question et je rejoins ce qui a été dit
sur la base saveurs de chine à paris
vous l'avez ont voté par les évidemment
on peut imaginer que la conversation
était un peu fraîche comme on dit
même si au fond l'ambassade a publié un
texte qui prétend dit-elle rétablir des
faits distordues mais qui en réalité les
remplace par des propos calomnieux je
suis un des 80 signataires parlementaire
française signataires et je n'ai pas
souvenir d'avoir signé ce qui nous est
prêté comme propos monsieur le ministre
que j'ai vous que vos échanges avec les
chinois lors de cette convocation est
alors votre entretien avec le ministre
des affaires étrangères de chine ont été
positives constructif
est ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura une
suite positive pour nous merci merci
richard au nom des rassemblement
démocratique et social européen rds jean
noël guérini
merci président bonjour monsieur
ministre a lors de son intervention le
président de la république n'a pas donné
de calendrier sur l'ouverture des
frontières aux pays hors espace schengen
cette ouverture passera-t-elle par une
décision commune européenne
quelles seront donc les contrôles mis en
place
va-t-on vers des 40 m pour autant de
citoyens français dans l'hexagone
et quelle sera la situation des
ressortissants étrangers
ma deuxième question dans son une
intervention de lundi dernier le
président de la république a plaidé pour
une annulation de la dette des pays
africains
comment engager des négociations et
monsieur le ministre avec les banques et
les organisations internationales
pour aboutir à cette mesure s'applique
aux sanitaires et en même temps et vous
l'avez indiqué des sommes importantes
vont être débloqués pour accompagner des
pays d'après quels seront les moyens de
paul mises en demeures et ma dernière
question s'il est bien trop tôt pour
tirer des leçons de fortes critiques ont
été unis sur la gestion de la crise par
l'om et plus particulièrement par le
président des états unis qui
malheureusement a décidé de cesser de
financer l'organisme
quel regard monsieur le ministre la
france
or cocktail sur les choix effectués ces
dernières semaines par cet organisme
je vous remercie merci jean noël pour le
cru liste écologiste
oui bonjour monsieur le ministre d'abord
aussi je me joins félicitations sur
l'effort de rapatriement des français à
l'étranger
juste une remarque là dessus je crois
que un point difficile persiste qui
concerne les camping caristes au maroc y
sont encore plusieurs milliers je sais
j'avais interrogé jean baptiste lemoyne
la semaine dernière qui me disait que
c'était en train d'être réglé il ya des
deux ferries qui sont affrétés le 8 et
le 16 mai mais il semble qu'il ya encore
beaucoup d'inquiétude parmi les
personnes concernées et que la dialogue
avec l'ambassade soit compliqué donc
voilà comme je continue d'être sollicité
sur cette question je la rapporte pour
que l'attention soit maintenue sur sur
ce point mais je ferai passer à
jean-baptiste lemoyne les les
informations dont je dispose à ce sujet
pour aider à régler cette situation
ensuite j'ai deux questions sur des
sujets majeurs que vous avez abordé la
première sur la crise du
multilatéralisme qui ne qui est mise en
exergue par la crise du colis de 19 mais
qui qui préexistait puisque nous en
avions déjà parlé et plusieurs fois avec
vous je suis frappée d'une chose vous
parler par exemple des appels du
secrétaire général de l'onu
personne n'en parle en france le
président de la république ne les évoque
jamais je pense que nous devrions
encourager davantage cette parole
international il souscrire de manière
plus vigoureuse de manière à encourager
les efforts qui sont faits d'autant que
la décision américaine de se retirer de
l'om s est proprement scandaleuse
elles mêmes indécente dans dans les
conditions actuelles
alors je sais qui devient très disons il
devient de mode de relayer aussi
des propos désobligeants à l'égard de l'
oms je pense que s'il ya un travail
important à mener ce serait plutôt un
travail de consolidation voire de
réforme mais en tout cas de
consolidation l' oms et je voulais vous
demander quel comment la france abordait
cette situation créée par l'annoncé
américaine et comment nous voulions
réagir à cela pour protéger cette
organisation mondiale la développer voir
la réforme et si nécessaire et ma
dernière question porte sur la question
de la dette africaine ce que vous avez
annoncé et qui semble se confirmer avec
la décision du g20 avec la décision de
la chine qui effectivement très
important est tout à fait nécessaire
je voulais vous demander si vous pensiez
pas qu'il fallait compléter cet effort
pour le rouble pérenne et durable par
une réflexion nouvelle sur les codes
d'investissement notamment en afrique
qui prive les pays africains de recettes
fiscales puisque très souvent les codes
d'investissement qui auront été mis en
place sous l'égide de la et du fmi et de
la banque mondiale exonère les
entreprises internationales qui
investissent en afrique est pressée pays
de recettes fiscales
est ce que nous n'avons pas besoin pour
que ces pays puissent construire des
systèmes sanitaires de restaurer leurs
recettes fiscales et d'envisager
autrement la matière la coopération avec
ces pays
merci monsieur le ministre merci pierre
enfin pour terminer le cycle des
orateurs de groupe jean louis lagourgue
pour les indépendants république et
territoires
monsieur le président c'est l'envol ou à
oui c'est robert alors alors que je vais
relayer le pas de problème donc monsieur
le ministre merci pour votre exposé pour
tout ce qui est fait pour nos
compatriotes rapatriés ou à rapatrier la
france présente dans les différents
océans atlantique indien pacifique et
dans les caraïbes
contre l'épidémie de covile 19 avec
quelques semaines de retard sur la
métropole dont collectivités d'outre-mer
ils font face avec les moyens
certainement plus important que la
plupart de leurs voisins régionaux tout
en soulignant cependant l'aide en
médecins que pourrait proposer certains
de ces états la france est liée à ces
régions ces états par des accords divers
et il joue un rôle important
souvent sollicitée est aussi très
appréciée sur le ministre voulait savoir
si le gouvernement envisage jeunes à
accueillir des malades atteints du
coville 19 venant de ces pays dans les
hôpitaux de nos collectivités dans la
région pacifique acp cyclone de
catégorie 5 a ravagé récemment plusieurs
archipels dont le vanuatu et aux liens
forts avec la france la nouvelle
calédonie serait-il possible de savoir
monsieur nenê ce qu'a pu être apportées
comme elle à cet archipel qui essaie de
se reconstruire tout en se protégeant
contre la propagation du cordat virus
également il est l'application de la
france dans le dispositif france
associée à notre pays à l'australie à la
nouvelle-zélande pour aider les
archipels ravagé je vous remercie
et si jean-louis monsieur le ministre je
vous invite à répondre à nos premiers
intervenants et je rappelle simplement
que j'ai après 13 collègues qui se sont
inscrits
oui mais je vais essayer de dette court
mais c'est revue les questions sont
importantes et pour répondre d'abord à
monsieur allizard ici de ne rien oublier
sur les informations que nous avons pu
avoir depuis la chine au début du
l'épidémie nous avons été informés par
notre consul général lahoud au mois de
janvier au moment où l'épidémie a pu
être c'est visible dans cette région et
à ce moment là nous avons nous sommes
organisés comme vous le savez pour faire
en sorte qu'il y ait de les
rapatriements de nos compatriotes dans
la zone et qui ont été rapatriés pendant
de bonnes conditions c'est la merde tu
étais là pour nous je fais remarquer
d'ailleurs à cet égard que le seul
consul général la seule équipe qu'ils
soient restés sur place pendant toute la
pandémie c'est l'équipe de retour du
consul général français y compris
d'ailleurs avec un entourage médical
donc je me j'en profite pour leur rendre
hommage parce que la france a et est
présente en permanence à one sur la
chine
je voudrais je réponds à plusieurs de
nos interlocuteurs vous avez vu mon
communiqué j'ai considéré que dans le la
manière dont le baladeur de chine en
france
navré l'ensemble observatoire il y avait
des mots et des petites maisons qui
n'étaient pas acceptables et je lui ai
fait savoir
et je dois dire que j'ai lu avec intérêt
ce matin la réaction du ministère
chinois des affaires étrangères qui a
longuement répondu sur précisant ceci je
vous lis et c'est beaucoup plus long que
ça je vais pas vous dire tous nos
commentaires mais l'ensemble du
commentaire est à la même heure
dans la même lignée la chine n'a pas
l'intention et ne fera pas de
commentaire sur l'inadaptation de la
réponse française à l'épidémie bien au
contraire
la chine est aux côtés de la france
façon qu'en dépit de l'épidémie nous
avons remarqué que sous la femme
direction du président bak
le gouvernement français a pris des
gestes barrières qui sont largement
soutenus par le peuple français et qui
ont un résident abouti à des résultats
positifs nous faisons sincèrement
l'éloge de cette action et nous
soutenons la france dans la mise en
oeuvre de mesures fortes en fonction de
sa propre situation et nous avons la
conviction que la france vaincra sans
aucun doute l'épidémie prochainement
moi je n'ai pas de commentaires
supplémentaires à faire de cette
déclaration
donc j'en prends acte avec intérêt mais
au-delà de cela dont je réponds à
plusieurs interrogations qui ont été
posées par les uns ou les autres sur ce
sujet mais au-delà de cela je voudrais
revenir sur d'autres points liés à la
chine parce que nous avons nous avons
avec la chine une relation qui est une
relation de clarté et aussi de fermeté
parce que ce pays vocation de établir un
nouveau multilatéralisme c'est une
concept que nous partageons mais il
aussi une tendance à faire en sorte que
ce nouveau multilatéralisme nike dans un
seul sens et donc nous avons avec la
chine discussions que locuteurs
incontournable une discussion sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets en particulier
lors des visites de mutuelle que nous
avons pu faire et que l'opposant n'a
plus qu'a fait en novembre 2019 en chine
et nous avons un dialogue de francs et
constructifs sur 3,3 série de sujets sur
lesquels nous travaillons ensemble avec
parfois des accords et des désaccords
mais dans la volonté d'établir à un
nouveau multilatéralisme à la fois en
déclinant travaillant sur la réciprocité
dans le domaine économique commercial
pour essayer d'obtenir des résultats
tangibles en agissant ensemble sur le
climat la biodiversité sensu
nous avons fait beaucoup de progrès et
donc il faut poursuivre cette
convergence est enfin en essayant
d'obtenir une meilleure convergence
entre l'initiative chinoise
une nouvelle route de la soie de la
stratégie européenne de connectivité
sont les moins long de nos discussions
nous respectons les intérêts et la
souveraineté de la chine et de la chine
doivent aussi respecter notre
souveraineté notre unité est aussi notre
présence européenne collective et c'est
sur ces sujets que nous avons les
dialogues permanent qui nous empêche pas
de dire ce que l'on pense comme vous
avez pu le constater lors de ma convoque
la convocation que j'ai fait à l'égard
de l'ambassadeur de chine en france mais
sur la crise du coronavirus nous avons
des discussions extrêmement étroite sur
les normes sur la qualité des
entreprises sur le pont aérien j'ai mon
collègue où on dit régulièrement au
téléphone pour éventuellement décoincer
des situations et faire en sorte qu'il y
ait de meilleures efficacités
relationnel sur la question des
capacités je pense en particulier aux
capacités en masque je voudrais dire
aussi alors monsieur à l'hiver je n'ai
pas d'information à ce moment sur la
l'évolution de la situation à tchernobyl
sur la sur les incendies qui sont à
proximité du site mais par contre l'aide
publique au développement mais je n'ai
pas connaissance qu'il ya eu des publics
au développement sur la construction de
la centrale de chablis ou alors je suis
mal informés mais ça m'étonnerait sur
les aides publiques au développement et
sur l'effacement de la dette
vous me demandez quel pays on république
ce sont les pays les plus en difficulté
mais pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
identifié ceux qui bénéficieront de ce
de ce dispositif
ce qui me frappe quand même c'est que
nous avons pu accélérer très vite sur
les moratoires et s'éteint c'est un bon
signe c'est une bonne évolution et je
pense que là
la tribune publiée dont je parlais il ya
un instant sur par les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement d'afrique et et de
l'union européenne avec aussi les deux
présidents de l'union de la commission
du nord africaines ou safa qui est
madame d'alien tout ça a beaucoup de
sens dans peut-être une nouveau type de
relations entre l'europe et l'afrique
concernant les dispositifs financiers
dispositifs fiscaux s'accompagne aussi
je les dis de tout à l'heure de deux
d'initiatives de la part du fonds
monétaire international pour la mise à
disposition de droit tirage spéciaux
pour certains pics et les plus jeunes
les plus en difficulté moi je suis
preneur des réflexions de change de
d'interlocuteurs excusez moi monsieur à
lisa mais comme monsieur laurent a fait
des propositions sur la modification des
codes d'investissement et la nécessité
d'avoir recours les pays africains
retrouve des disponibilités fiscalement
je suis preneur d'essayer de ces
propositions puisqu'il suit de j'essaie
de très près toutes ces questions sur l'
oms
c'est toujours monsieur allizard et
c'est aussi plusieurs d'entre vous qui
avait posé cette question je dois dire
que nous regrettons la position
américaine pensons que c'est dommage
quand il ya une pandémie que le seul
outil de coopération mondiale soit en
mise en difficulté par ce rôle
cette décision de renoncer à soutenir
financièrement cet outil pense que
l'outil oms c'est à nous d'y important
il a un énorme hâtif savez que c'est euh
ouais mais ça doit dire le droit
international sur la santé dans le cadre
de repas réguliers du règlement
sanitaire international de rsi tatin
punk inapte à 2 entraîne pas de
contrainte si tel ou tel état ne met pas
en application il n'y a pas de capacité
de sanctions mais il y à ce rôle
normatif
il ya un rôle d' alerte d'information
pour objectiver les menaces sanitaires
déclaré qu'il y avait pire ennemi puis
le pandémie et il ya aussi un rôle de
coordination son ensemble des 150
bureaux que le ms à part le monde c'est
important d'avoir ces réseaux avec le
tout à cela le rôle de formation il y
aura bientôt un an et demi de la santé à
lyon initiée dans le cadre de l' oms et
dans la décision est prise en novembre
dernier lorsque le fonds mondial s'est
réuni à à lyon puis le web est ce un
rôle aussi de détection et d'assistance
technique
il ya sans doute des choses à dire sur
le fonctionnement mais peut-être de
manque de réactivité peut-être mans que
d'autonomie par rapport aux états
peut-être manque de moyens de détection
manque de moyens d'alerté d'information
manque aussi de capacité normative mais
ce n'est pas automatiquement de la
responsabilité des acteurs actuels de
l'om est ce c'est aussi dans les
fondamentaux de la de l'institution qui
est je pense que la crise actuelle
devrait nous permettre de revoir le rôle
de chacun des grands outils qui existent
aujourd'hui le seul ayant une vocation
internationale si l'om est confortée et
la france soit au rendez vous avec
l'europe pour le conforter mais au-delà
de cela il faudra trouver ce qui n'est
pas suffisant aujourd'hui des bonne
articulation entre l' oms qui est le
cadre général qui est reconnu par les
nations unies et des outils comme le
fonds mondial de lutte contre le sida
com de com le gavi pour l'épauler
vaccins comme l'unitaid pour l'épauler
brevets et faire en sorte que chaque
outil trouve sa place et son rôle pour
que demain ne soit pas dans une
situation où on est mais ce n'est pas
encore suffisamment à maturité de ses
fonctions on pourrait dire ça comme ça
en tout cas c'est notre volonté je vais
rajouter un point qui
correspond à des questions qui ont été
posées par les uns ou par les autres qui
n'est pas ronde et donc nous avions
lancé avec mon collègue allemand heiko
maas à new york l'année dernière une
initiative
j'ai au multilatéralisme
nous avions souhaité on sait qu'il
fallait pas passer son temps à se
plaindre
la crise du multilatéralisme et essayer
de faire en sorte qu'on puisse celui
retrouvé une nouvelle dynamique et nous
avions été surpris de lorsque cette
initiative d'avoir été suivi par 70 pays
et 70 ministres présents l'assemblée
générale des nations unies qui montrent
qu'il y avait une attente nous avons
décidé ensemble de prendre des
initiatives demain pour que l'alliance
pour le multilatéralisme que nous avons
initié puisse se faire des propositions
de réforme et d'amélioration du système
sanitaire international pour rendre plus
cohérent plus dynamique et plus
pertinente l'ensemble des outils qui
sont aujourd'hui à la disposition pour
aussi aussi d'éclairer les choix
financiers qu'ils peuvent être articulée
à cette initiative donc de plusieurs
pays vont nous rejoindre dans cette
réunion interne que nous ferons
visioconférence demain et je pense si je
pense que vous les citer tous j'ai la
liste des membres sous les yeux est en
tout cas cette situation nous permet
peut-être de refonder un
multilatéralisme de la santé qui soit
profite de l'expérience antérieure de
l'om est ce qu'ils essaient de tirer les
leçons de la crise et qu'ils puissent
bâtir un nouveau dispositif cohérente ou
pas c'est un appel que nous allons
lancer ensemble avec aussi le relais de
l'union européenne croit avoir répondu à
6 sur le l'organisation mondiale de la
santé à plusieurs autres intervenants
je voudrais dire
à monsieur boutant que sur relais sur
les affaires de conditionnalité petrov
sur les questions de seconde dans le sur
la chine les réponses nécessaires
d'autant plus que puisqu'ils ne parlait
de la dette et de drôles que la chine
pouvait avoir initié en endettant un
certain nombre de pays africains
le fait que désormais au moins sur les
actifs déposés hier la chine contribue à
au moratoire c'est un pour la première
fois un signe positif à ses dégâts
jusqu'à présent la chine estimé ne pas
de vouloir faire partie du club de paris
là c'est pas le club de paris c'est le
club paris pousse la chine mais c'est
une un point intéressant à souligner
vous interroger sur la conditionnalité
sur le sur le plan de relance fait
observer que d'abord en ce qui concerne
l'accès au mécanisme européen de
stabilité qui a été mobilisée lors de la
réunion de l'eurogroupe de la semaine
dernière les normes de conditionnalité
qui existait auparavant supprimés et la
seule conditionnalité pour mobiliser des
financements dans le cadre du mécanisme
européen de stabilité ce sont des
affectations financières liées à la
crise est liée au secteur santé donc ce
n'est pas la mise en oeuvre ce reliquat
comme on a pu le voir antérieurement et
concernant le blues le futur plan de
relance
il ne s'agit pas d'une resucée d'un
dispositif antérieur il s'agit du
nouveau long et d'emprunter
collectivement des fonds permettant la
relance de l'investissement tout le
monde étant sur un pied d'égalité et
tout le monde
assumant l'emprunt collectif pour la
relance chacun feu après faisant les
choix nécessaires pour ses propres
propos plans de relance nationaux
c'est une nouvelle donne j'espère
qu'elle va aller jusqu'au bout et que le
23 avril lors du conseil européen
tout cela pourra être décidée je profite
de monsieur boutant mais je réponds
aussi à d'autres en même temps
sur la vf c'est aussi une manière de
répondre à monsieur katic sur ce sur ce
sujet et sans rien monsieur young aussi
on voit bien que healy a aujourd'hui une
clé dynamo propos introductif une triple
difficulté il y a le fait que les écoles
ne fonctionne plus donc ça veut dire des
pertes de recettes donc pour les
établissements c'est une difficulté
particulière surtout pour eux des petits
établissements qui sont des
établissements partenaires ils sont pas
automatiquement des établissements
gestion directe quand même beaucoup dans
le monde qui risque d'être de voir même
leur propre avenir
remise en cause parce que ces
établissements aussi des des élèves qui
sont qui ne sont pas des français et
qu'ils sont victimes ou si des
situations économiques particulièrement
difficiles que chaque pays connaît
actuellement donc à la question des
établissements et la question des
familles de français et ils droit
d'inscrire des droits de scolarité mais
aussi des boxeurs nécessaire et puis il
ya la question de la ffe elle-même
donc c'est tout cela qui fait l'objet du
plan de relance est évidemment mais ce
qu'a dit que ça voudrait dire que sur
les bourses et sur l'autre et sur les
185 il y aura sûrement des modifications
je suis pas encore en mesure de vous
développer tout ce blanc qui est en
cours de discussion dans jean baptiste
lemoyne assure la responsabilité
concrètes mais très rapidement ce plan
de relance sera mis sur la table
j'espère qu'il pourra répondre aux
préoccupations que vous avez vous avez
le fait par et pour les familles
étrangères et des rats aussi des êtres
puisque on ne peut pas continuer on a
aussi là un outil d'influencé qui est
absolument indispensable à conserver sur
monsieur k dick toujours les les
veilleux jeunes actifs moi je suis prêt
à regarder le sont peuvent reposer
je n'ai pas d'autres techniques à faire
à cet instant mais je suis prêt à
regarder cette proposition sur
monsieur young de deux points
complémentaires par rapport à ce que
vous avez comment est ce que vous avez
dit qu'elle soit sur lesquels je n'ai
pas répondu encore sur l'appel du 23
mars
d'ailleurs monsieur laurent n'a fait
aussi état l'appel du secrétaire général
pour la trêve humanitaire
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu depuis cette date
de beaucoup de discussions initiées par
il ya eu beaucoup de discussions
initiées par par la france à la suite de
l'appel de la terre général dans des
relations directes entre le président de
la république et le président chinois
avait aussi le président poutine et des
présidents toi mais je ne souhaitant que
le p5 puisse porter le point de vue du
secrétaire général l'euro plus loin dans
leurs préoccupations et souhaite
vraiment nous souhaitons vraiment et je
pense qu'on va y arriver que la
visioconférence du p5 qui sera un
événement politique de grande ampleur
puisse se tenir dans les dans les plus
brefs délais je me suis moi même
entretenu sur cette question avec le
ministre - me2me chinois des affaires
étrangères il ya un poids que monsieur
young soulevait faisant référence à une
haute autorité de la santé
c'est un propos que j'ai tenus devant
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière en faisant remarquer que il
aurait il serait très utile d'avoir un
instance indépendante fait d'experts des
meilleurs scientifiques qu'ils puissent
alerter et identifier les risques et des
menaces au niveau mondial dans le
domaine de la santé la santé humaine
mais aussi de la santé animale d'en
faire un lien et d'être comme le giec
pour le climat l'interpellateur avec à
côté nous
gide à sion qui est l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
je pense que cette idée mérite d'être
creusée en tout cas il est certain que
on sera amenés après cette crise nous
réinterroger sur l'ensemble du
dispositif et sur l'ensemble de la
stratégie de santé dans le monde sur ce
bien commun de la santé pour l'ensemble
de la communauté internationale
peut-être revenir sur un certain nombre
de principes et des engagements qui
avaient été pris juste après la guerre
39-45 créer les outils multilatéraux est
ce que nous allons essayer de faire avec
l'alliance pour le multilatéralisme je
parlais tout à l'heure rentrer dans
cette problématique
c'est ma manière de répondre à la fois
interrogations sur la haute autorité de
la santé pense que ce concept né vite
qu'on explore lorsque le giec
propositions il a acquis une telle
notoriété un tel respect que ça fait
bouger les lignes et ça entraîne
l'action il faudrait qu'il y ait dans le
domaine de la santé après cette crise le
même dispositif jeu
on revient sur monsieur guérini je
m'interrogeais sur le web est je crois
avoir répondu globalement à 7 sur cette
instance sur l'ouverture des frontières
la gestion de des frontières européennes
de la gestion de l'espace européen qui
est est fermé c'est à dire c'est
schengen l'union européenne et l'euro
munich qui ont fermé leurs frontières
externes
cette décision a été prise par
l'ensemble des européens elle est
toujours maintenue
c'était au conseil européen du 17 mars
c'est donc aussi ensemble entre
européens que la décision de sera prise
de leur ouvrir mais je pense que dans la
situation actuelle ce n'est pas comme
dirait ma république dans son
intervention lundi ce n'est pas pour
demain matin encore il faudra sans doute
élire continuer à exercer le contrôle au
niveau des frontières intérieures mais
l'espace européen qui a été fermé et
très récemment il ya un mois maintenant
plus d'un mois
elle restera fermée encore pendant
quelques temps mais ce n'est pas
uniquement la france qui prend sa
décision mais je pense que l'évolution
va dans ce sens jeune et j'ai répondu en
partie à monsieur laurent sauf cela crée
multilatérale et je crois avoir anticipé
sur votre interrogation dans ce que j'ai
dit sur les initiatives que nous voulons
que nous voulons prendre sur la peine se
fait en général aussi jeux vedettes
africaines je vous ai dit shaw les
camping cars je deviens monsieur laurent
un professionnel et camping cars
pour tout vous dire pour que vous
sachiez tous nous avons affrété deux
bateaux
pour ramener je croise des 400 camping
car nous sommes au lard et
malheureusement le deuxième bateau il
reste des places
parce qu'un certain nombre de
camping-cars et ce qu'ils sont à agadir
ont estimé qu'ils pouvaient rester
agadir faire leur confinement et que
c'est un peu plus tard qu'ils se sont
dit bah finalement faudrait peut-être
entrer que s'il peut y avoir que j'aime
tout confiance à notre ambassadrice au
maroc est depuis passée de moments à peu
compliqué il faut savoir si on veut
aussi on veut pas à partir du moment où
on est en situation de vacance ou s'ils
sont provisoires au maroc sinon la
frontière est fermée et donc c'est à
chaque fois c'est des autorisations et
donc nos amis camping caristes ne se
rendent pas compte de temps qu'on a
passé pour régler les deux premiers
bateaux
alors moi je veux bien accorder un
troisième mais il faudrait que les gens
qui lèvent le doigt de 10
ok on sera au rendez vous si vous les
connaissez
merci de le leur dire ensuite je sur le
la question concernant la situation en
polynésie moi j'ai eu l'occasion enfin
dans le pacifique j'ai eu l'occasion
d'un sénateur de d'évoquer toutes ces
questions hier avec mon collègue néo
zélandais et et aussi il y à peu avec
mon collègue australien je pense que
nous avons sommes bien mobilisés autour
d'eux concernant le l'ouragan harold et
qui était la priorité avant avant toute
chose face à face au au virus et nous
avons une coopération dans le cadre de
france qui est tout à fait pertinente
sur lequel moi je n'ai jamais eu de
critiques de dessins ou des autres y
compris deux de la nullité de nos deux
premières et par ailleurs concernant
l'assistance sanitaire nous avons des
accords avec le les différents pays qui
permettent d évacuation sanitaire de 6,6
et si c'est nécessaire et nous avons un
envoi de frais de sanitaires en cours
pour l'ensemble de la région qui va être
acheminé par de movea pour la crise que
pas connu le vanuatu
voilà ce que je pouvais dire je m'excuse
d'avoir été peut-être un peu long mais
ça m'a permis de conduite et montreront
initial complètement et là maintenant
monsieur le président c'est pour moi
c'est dès 18h25
bon alors j'ai horreur demande de paul
donc faut vraiment que chacune et chacun
d'entre vous respecte la règle
sacro-sainte d'une minute maximale
faute de quoi évidemment les derniers ne
seront pas les premiers
gilbert roger une minute vas-y rue
gibert gilbert roger
alors s'il est pas là on passe à jean
marie bockel
je mets mon micro coupé en style
télégraphique président très bien ce que
vous avez sur l'afrique très bien que le
président il fait allusion hier
focus sur le g5 sahel en parallèle
d'ailleurs avec les créations
bien qu'un général de l'agencé française
de développement cette semaine on est à
un moment dans la presse alliance à elle
tout se met en place pour le redémarrage
est comme un hobby économies là où c'est
possible
tout ça est impacté par la crise
sanitaire
mais je crois que l'état d'esprit dans
le partenariat avec ces pays
c'est que on ne lâche pas la proie pour
l'ombre et j'aimerais bien vous entendre
confirmé qu'en même temps que le soutien
sanitaire il ya la poursuite soutien au
développement
je fêterai merci jean marc et jean
pierre vial allez on va très vite
j'suis en ligne alors gilbert allez on
revient sur gilbert effet sur nous voilà
une question franco française
quand est ce que vous pensez donner un
feu vert au restaurant café camping pour
éventuellement reprendre des activités à
l'époque estivale de juillet ou ou est
ce que ça sera fermée toujours pas de
déconfinement dans ces domaines là merci
giesbert j'ai peur que ce soit pas
totalement la compétence du ministre
mais enfin il s'expliquera lui-même
jean pierre vial jean-pierre inédit
n'est pas là ah bon alors appelé surtout
mis à piller bell micro vas-y
jean-pierre oui voilà une des ministres
après la déclaration qu'ils avaient fait
il ya une semaine sur l'afrique
on va remercie sur cet apport que la
commission suit de près il ya aussi la
situation préoccupante des zones de
guerre ou permettrait d'évoquer la
question du moyen-orient l'irak la syrie
le liban
ces trois pays sont en interaction très
forte et plus particulièrement la syrie
après la période de guerre il ya
situation économique dramatique de la
population est bien évidemment
aujourd'hui avec la crise sanitaire les
humanitaires les ong
des églises rencontres les plus grandes
difficultés on sait très bien que au
delà des l'ambarrois des sanctions qui
ont été adaptés au niveau français et
européen il ya surtout la pesanteur de
la position américaine
face à cette situation le secrétaire
général de l'onu monsieur antonio perez
a fait appel à la nécessité de la
mobilisation du conseil de sécurité
rappelait par le parti et tout récemment
ou par le président battrons est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire où on en est de
cette situation de la possibilité du
conseil de sécurité et l'évolution des
choses au moyen-orient et en syrie en
particulier
merci jean pierre joëlle garriaud-maylam
une minute appuyé bien sûr votre micro
pour parler du réel
c'est ce que j'ai fait allons-y je vais
je suis misogyne
bon c'est pas vrai non quand on t'entend
vas-y vas-y fais oui merci pour ce que
vous avez fait pour nos 160 mille
compatriotes
monsieur le ministre il reste une poche
de problèmes avec des enfants adoptés en
haïti devait venir les parents en
guadeloupe n'ont pas pu récupérer les
enfants le vol a été annulé
notre vallée part pour la france ensuite
ils sont restés en haïti doit
effectivement il faut vraiment vraiment
aider ces familles s'il vous plaît
monsieur le ministre et auditions comme
vous avez parlé de la chine avec mes
collègues mais ya quand même une
question sur taïwan jeu c'est peut-être
une question extrêmement difficile j'ai
vraiment la france honoré de prendre une
initiative diplomatique avec le soutien
des européens en ce moment pour essayer
de faire rentrer taïwan dans le cadre
onusien c'est un état partenaire 27
millions de taiwanais qui les
partenaires économiques et fiables
démocratique
je crois vraiment qu'il mérite notre
soutien merci joël jean marc todeschini
merci le président je n'ai ni frein
jean-yves jeu réintervient j'ai
interpellé jean baptiste lemoyne
récemment sur le sujet
mais j'aurai intervient sur le problème
des travailleurs frontaliers chez nous
ici en moselle l'europe c'est tout rires
jaunes des 19 bill frontaliers qui passe
en sarre dans civils allemands qui
habite en france c'est 4000 qui vont
vers la rhénanie palatinat certains
depuis la fermeture des frontières 5
points de base alors qu'avant il y en
avait tout au long de la frontière entre
la sar qui allait d'un suite sur
luxembourg et c'est pareil pour ceux qui
descendent en belgique
la moselle mais c'est pareil ailleurs et
je sais ils ont baptiste lemoyne qui m'a
dit qu'il regarderait j'ai saisi
l'ambassadeur d'allemagne qui m'a
répondu mais qu'il a fait dans une
interview à public alors un rien ne
s'améliore
rien ne s'améliore certains frontaliers
sont obligés de faire 50 km au cul ce
matin pour aller un des cinq postes
frontières qui leur permettent de passer
lorsqu'ils arrivent au poste frontière
je parle pas du temps où une fois tendre
pour présenter des laissez passer
donc tout cela je sais que c'est le
traité de schengen qui permet la
fermeture des frontières 30 jours
maximum renouvelable
on peut aller à deux mois mais pourquoi
je serai intervient aujourd'hui tout
simplement parce qu'elle ministre des
affaires étrangères les affaires ni de
l'intérieur allemand a dit hier qu'il
allait probablement annoncé une
prolongation de ce2 la fermeture des
points de passage jusqu'aux boîte mais
c'est honnêtement pour des gens qui
vivent comme nous l'a l'europe tous les
jours des et chante en permanence
l'allemagne c'est de l'autre côté de la
rue devoir faire des centaines de
kilomètres
matin et soir pour aller travailler ça
devient invivable je pense aussi que la
volonté du populisme va monter je
reviendrai pas sur des excuses a dû
faire elle compare à haikou par les
français qui sont fait insulter au
passage aux postures contraire c'est sûr
que l'allemagne a déclaré le grand test
zones à risque donc tout cela il
faudrait qu'on ne comptait revenir il
faudrait au moins n'ont pas ouvrir tous
les postes frontières je comprends que
les allemands veulent se protéger mais
au moins regarder dans le secteur de
bouzonville on a des secteurs où ne sait
vraiment infernal des gens 150 km pour
aller travailler de l'autre côté de chez
eux
donc monsieur le ministre j'aimerais
bien qu'on regarde
de plus près parce que c'est une europe
que l'on vit donc en permanence merci
jean marc gilbert luc devinaz il merci
monsieur le président l'institut
administ de nous accorder un peu de
temps de votre temps comment la crise
que vit de vatel vais interroger le sens
de l'aide publique au développement
l'objectif est notamment dans les
programmes de mise en oeuvre par ait des
merci merci albert luque pour ta
concision robert del picchia oui
monsieur le ministre
ça fait des années que je vous adresse
mes félicitations votre nombre n'obtint
ne fait qu'augmenter
donc c'est aussi valable pour cette
année mais je suis déçu pour revenir sur
la ffe alors on va me dire encore la
veille que tout le monde à paris mais
monsieur le ministre la ffe est en train
de prendre un très mauvais chemin et
c'est très très importante que voulez
vous dire parce que nous allons au mois
de novembre ou décembre prochain avoir
de très grandes difficultés à cause des
parents d'élèves étrangers qui auront
retiré leurs enfants
j'ai des exemples partout de gens qui
inscrivent déjà dans des écoles locales
parce qu'ils ne sont pas sûrs que des
mesures qui vont être prises seront
suffisantes pour maintenir le bon
fonctionnement de la vie un peu et je
sais c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
crédible peut-être mais en tout cas
c'est le cas et on aura des problèmes
je crois monsieur le ministre on dit je
suis rapporteur budgétaire avec andré
vallini on voulaient interviewer le
directeur de la vf on nous dit
d'attendre l'annoncé du plan que vous
allez faire le nom du plan qui va être
un plan comme vous l'avez dit qu'il sera
très important avec une aide massive à
laver que c'est très important et ça va
marcher
les bourses très bien même si on a des
bourses à tous les français d'étrangers
on pourrait peut-être le faire mais ça
ne suffit pas et ça ne suffira pas de
toute façon parce que il y aura le
problème des étrangers qui ont des
difficultés
le problème c'est que l'essai parlons
des étrangers sont inquiet de l'avenir
des écoles françaises ils ont sent
inquiet et je crois qu'il faut les
rassurer
alors monsieur le ministre pour le plan
très bien mais je crois qu'il faut un
plan de communication
très important pour les parents d'élèves
et des parents d'élèves étrangers alors
pas le le proviseur ou le directeur
scientifique rappaz pas il faut quelque
chose de très très haut niveau il faut
une communication de la part du ministre
e même plus gros peut-être pour as tu
trouvé tous les fragments d'élèves à
l'étranger qui sont français merci merci
robert xori merci président monsieur le
ministre merci pour vos propos merci
aussi pour les efforts du ministère pour
rapatrier les ressortissants français
à ce propos vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que ça avait été une situation
extrêmement compliquée à gérer
or les virologues et les
épidémiologistes disent que la pandémie
il va durer probablement longtemps et
qu'elle connaîtra des périodes de
rémission mais aussi des rebonds ce qui
veut dire que probablement là que nous
avons connu risque de se reproduire dans
six mois ou dans un an
aujourd'hui quels enseignements peut-on
tirer pour à la fois faciliter le
travail des ministères lorsque ça se
reproduira et pour sécuriser les voyages
de nos compatriotes toujours merci merci
je ne perde pas de temps rien n'entend
plus rien tentant
vous m'entendez oui on t'entend vas-y
très bien merci merci président et merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre
engagement sans faille
celui de votre équipe aussi au cabinet
qui est vraiment très très réactive et
puis bien sûr l'ensemble des équipes
dans nos consulats et vous dire que bien
nous restons mobilisés nous attendons
avec impatience
en effet les les annonces que vous allez
faire dans la mise en place d'actions
concrètes suite aux annonces pour sauver
la vie moi ma question est très simple
c'est pour revenir sur le côté sanitaire
et là je m'adresse le chef de la
diplomatie française nous avons facilité
le retour et français de passage à
l'étranger
le conseil que vous donnez à suivre à
l'étranger et de rester dans les pays
pour l'instant mais quid des étrangers
résidents permanents en france est ce
que aujourd'hui
après donc la première vague leur tour
de france est de passage
il est prévu quelque chose pour des
étrangers qui résident de façon
permanente en france et je voudrais
aussi et élargir la question posée tout
à l'heure en bocaux l'oeil sur les
outre-mer est ce que nous sommes en
capacité de d'apporter une aide
notamment je pense certain nombre de
ministres ou pina faso qui sont
contaminés par le grenat virus
d'apporter une aide à certains pays qui
ne l'oublieront pas jeu après là nous
sommes vraiment dans le domaine de la
diplomatie et de faire en sorte est bien
de pouvoir accueillir un certain nombre
de personnes notamment dans des pays qui
sont qui sont plutôt faibles et qui ont
besoin que le gouvernement fonctionne
je vous remercie merci hélène marie
françoise pérol dumont vous entendez
monsieur le président you we monsieur le
ministre merci de votre présence est
toujours est il que d'échanger avec vous
dans cette pollution
ma question sera très spécifique elle
portera sur l'afrique le président de la
république dans une interview qui la
jouent pas donné hier à rfi
parler de la solidarité que nous devons
à l'afrique
c'est effectivement un devoir
humanitaire mais c'est aussi et vous
l'avez développer la soliste au delà de
notre devoir c'est aussi notre strict
intérêt pour éviter beaucoup de choses
mais pour éviter entre autres un reflux
sud-nord de la pandémie
ma question porte sur une toile très
précis au-delà de l'aide que nous
pouvons apporter dans la gestion
immédiate de la hand et comment
pouvons-nous intervenir et vous avez
fais allusion à la recherche
scientifique pour aider bien sûr les
antennes des de l'institut pasteur et
nous avons pu lors de déplacement à
madagascar par la qualité de travail qui
a été fait dans cet institut avec des
moyens limités et j'imagine que c'est la
même chose dans les autres instituts
mais au delà pour les africains les
épidémies pendant les épidémiologue
africains dont beaucoup sont de grande
qualité de très nombreux sont de grande
qualité
comment pouvons-nous les aider parce
qu'il ya la gestion immédiate de la
pandémie et il y aura la gestion de
l'après vous avez des références aux
échanges de données aux échanges de
bonnes pratiques
mais ne serait-il pas souhaitable ne
serait-il pas possible de les aider
également au plan logistique au plan des
infrastructures et au delà du fonds
mondial il a été fait référence le
président de la république a parlé du
fonds mondial
mais le fonds mondial il a déjà des
affectations est déjà affectée à la
lutte contre le vih et la lutte contre
la tuberculose donc quels outils
internationaux encore français européens
et internationaux pourraient être
mobilisés à cet effet pour penser
l'après pandémie je vous remercie
merci enfin on a perdu l'image du
ministre
bernat vous m'entendez la wii sur
revenus on entrerait le son mais pas
l'image il ya plus d'image non c'est
dommage pour vous un baisse bien sûr
mais ça n'empêche pas bernard cazeau de
poser sa question et sortez moi de temps
en temps des bruits on attend bernard
bazille honte à être jouée pas c'est une
question très très courte alors être
rapide concernant une question n'a pas
été évoquée le sexe du conflit sur le
royaume n est ce que vous pensez
monsieur le ministre que c'est une
décision temporaire l'arabie saudite
actuellement d'arrêter le conflit ou
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
décision qui risque d'aller ensuite j'ai
une résolution de ce conflit
l'arabie saoudite at elle marqué ainsi
essentiellement et une opération volonté
de traiter cette affaire ou seulement
celles de se donner un petit peu de
calme pendant ce la période de chronos
merci bernard là parce que vous ne
faites pas d'erreur c'est pas moi le
ministre est ce que le ministre entend
ou bien l'inter 2002 vous entends mais
je ne vous vois si ces amoureux voir je
suis réapparu à très bien parfait la lui
helg herriot il faut recadrer un peu
l'image voilà très bien on a des vues
sur le coffre-fort
monsieur matériaux monsieur le ministre
je vous adresse quelques rayons de
soleil de protec puisque dans cet
important
je voudrais parler du vivant très
rapidement on sent aviez vous l'avez
évoqué mais c'est un pays qui souffre
économiquement depuis octobre 2019
puisqu'il accueille elle un million cinq
cent mille réfugiés s'est attaqué en
faillite alors qu'il le sera encore
davantage puisque maintenant ils sont
confinés jusqu'au 15 mai selon le
gouvernement ce sont des personnes que
l'on peut pas aider puisqu'on peut pas
faire de virement sur le liban et
ne pas partir de 100 euros par semaine
focus qui sont très très compliqué qu'il
ne risque plus que de s'aggraver
ils ont vu un contrôle de la banque
mondiale partiel donc qu'est ce qu'on
pourra faire pour eux comment pourrons
nous aider le liban qui est comme un
pays très proche de notre culture et de
nos racines
merci tu as dernier orateur ladislas
poniatowski il faut ouvrir au micro ça
marche
oui on t'entend vas-y monsieur le
ministre je ne partage pas du tout votre
optimisme sur le nu et notamment sur qui
s'est passé le 23 mars auquel vous avez
fait allusion tout à l'heure ce jour là
le secrétaire général de l'onu a lancé à
un appel à cesser le feu mondiale ça a
été plutôt un fiasco parce qu'il ya donc
trois pays ça un petit peu bougé au
yémen en syrie et en libye mais
globalement même au yémen ça n'a pas
très bien marché et dans le reste des
zones mondiales où il ya des conflits
ça n'a pas marché et monsieur le
ministre je vous trouve un optimiste je
suis très pessimiste
tout est bloqué à l'onu puisque déjà au
niveau du cinq membres permanents
il ya un blocage monsieur trempe refuse
la plaie cette endémie le corps navires
us il apaise 7 en débit le virus chinois
pour bien montrer la situation de
blocage entre deux des cinq donc ma
question monsieur le ministre
est-ce que ce truc comme disait le
général de gaulle sert encore à quelque
chose
merci la distance alors j'ai encore
olivier cigolotti qu'il n'aurait pas le
temps à il va être la toute dernière les
oliviers très vite
- il s'appelle olivier cigolotti merci
oui vous m'entendez oui en teintes
invasive
monsieur le ministre merci je voulais
revenir rapidement sur la situation en
afrique nous l'avait dit pour l'instant
la situation sanitaire est contenue
pourtant d'ores et déjà des millions
d'emplois sont menacés les secteurs du
tourisme et du transport aérien sont
déjà particulièrement touché les cours
des matières premières sont en chute
libre et les transferts des différentes
diasporas sont d'ores et déjà en forte
baisse
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple ne pensez vous pas que le
principal risque pour l'afrique soit la
récession économique des principaux
partenaires de ce continent
merci voilà messieurs le mini c'est à
vous dans le temps que vous nous
accordez encore merci monsieur le
président je suis un peu ennuyé parce
que je vous ferai sans doute pas
répondre à tout le monde
je prends les points qui me sont apparus
les plus centraux et sur lesquelles je
n'étais pas encore intervenue d'abord
sur la f10 monsieur delpy k way et
d'autres ont fait part préoccupations
des risques que cela représentait si on
ne prenait pas des initiatives fortes
je partage et pour l'instant je ne peux
qu'adresser un message politique fort de
notre volonté d'agir pour faire en sorte
que l'aef tiennent le coup pendant cette
période qu'elle soit au service des
enfants de nos ressortissants mais aussi
au service des enfants de familles qui
veulent faire en sorte que les études de
leurs enfants se fassent sous influence
française et dans une école française et
je sais que certains s'interrogent sur
l'avenir et donc le message est fort
maintiendrons la ffe dans ces vocations
c'est pas uniquement le message du
ministre des affaires étrangères mais
c'est aussi le message du président la
république puisque certains d'entre vous
en fait état de son interview à radio
france internationale où il a dit les
choses avec une très grande fermeté et
donc je voulais vous rassurer sur ma
détermination et notre détermination à
agir je sais que le allait elle est
partagée
je ne suis pas madame conway je ne suis
pas je suis je suis favorable à ce que
l'on puisse et des les pays à combattre
leurs africains combattre l'évolution de
la pandémie mais je pense qu'il faut les
aider dans leur territoire sur leur
territoire parce que nous pouvons
apporter l'aide nécessaire avec la
mobilisation financière que j'ai
indiquées dans mon propos introductif le
mettre en place pour assurer la
détection le soin la protection c'est la
mission de que nous avons c'est la
mission de la sb c'est la mission de
l'union européenne à développer c'est la
mission de l'ensemble des acteurs qui
sont aujourd'hui au rendez vous ainsi
que je les ai indiqué tout à l'heure sur
la syrie monsieur vial j'y allais j
allais faire illusion que je sais pas si
j'ai été suffisamment explicite sur le
sujet tout à l'heure que dès que pendant
la situation en syrie
politiquement ne bouge pas et le
dispositif qui a été mis en place à
genève n'aboutit pas le conseil
constitutionnel ne produit pas les
engagements
sa vocation ne n'est pas au rendez vous
de sa vocation et que par ailleurs il y
assure la partie nord ouest mais aussi
sur la partie nord-est d'une situation
très difficile pour des populations de
réfugiés et de déplacés voire de
prisonniers et nous nous souhaitons que
l'on puisse avoir un accès humanitaire à
ces sauts et la france et est au rendez
vous puisque nous avons mobilisé 50
millions de
pour l'aspect humaniste pour l'aide
humanitaire qui est aujourd'hui aussi je
l'aide sanitaire en pratique les dans la
zone 13 au nord ouest
l'évolution politique de lenche si rien
aujourd'hui ne laisse pas beaucoup de
perspectives positives
d'ailleurs encore faut-il que nous
puissions déjà aidé à ce qu' il y ait
pas trop de drames dans la partie dans
les zones où il ya le plus de réfugiés
et de déplacés sur la question de jean
marie bockel
en réalité vous
le dispositif qui a été mis en place à
pau continue et est donc malgré la crise
du coronavirus il ya eu des élections au
mali utile deuxième tour des élections
doivent avoir lieu dimanche prochain les
grands engagements qui avaient été pris
au moment de nous sommait de pau j'avais
dit à l'époque c'était à la fois le
sommet de la gravité mais aussi le le
sommet de l'unité le sommet de la
clarification et de la remobilisation et
l'ensemble de ses objectifs continus
malgré tout malgré les difficultés quand
on au tchad contre boko haram mais
l'ensemble du dispositif y compris la
force conjointe qui compte pas eux les
les actions de barkan les compris la
mise en oeuvre ou pas ils comprirent la
mise en oeuvre de l'action humanitaire
se poursuivre il vous faites bien de
rappeler cela parce qu'on pourrait de
sous-estimer lens cette période et
éventuellement même l'oublier monsieur
gilbert roger sur ce n'est pas de la
compétence de vous dire là à quel moment
les restaurants et les hôtels ouvriront
le président a de mixer
prononcer lundi sur un agenda qui est
lié aussi à l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire est donc il appartiendra en
temps opportun en temps utile de 7 à
viser sur l'ouverture des restaurants et
les hôtels mais ce que je peux vous dire
par contre monsieur roger c'est que nous
allons mettre en place avec
jean-baptiste lemoyne un dispositif de
soutien et de sauvetage à toutes les
entreprises liées liées au tourisme et à
ce type de proximité parce que c'est une
autre profession qui souffre qui
souffrent beaucoup en ce moment et qu'il
le peut importe d'accompagner dans dans
cette période avec un plan spécifique
annoncé le premier ministre sur les
observations sur le monsieur des menaces
sur l'aide publique au développement
l'afd va reprogrammer des crédits pour
refaire des priorités en intégrant la
dimension
kovy de 19 et le combat contre la
pandémie
donc on va pas oublier les autres
secteurs mais on réorienter les
financements pour être à ce rendez vous
majeur qui nécessite aujourd'hui de
doubler toutes les priorités sur
monsieur sorry je ne suis pas prophète
je peux vous dire comment tout ça se
passera dans l'avenir mais il est
certain que les habitudes de
déplacements vont sûrement changer
modifier aussi les compatriotes je ne
vais pas anticiper j'espère qu'il y aura
pas d'autres pandémies puisque vous
étiez un peu dans cet esprit et j'espère
qu'on arrivera rapidement à endiguer
celle ci mais il est certain que ça va
entraîner des modifications de
comportement je voudrais préciser à
madame rivaux à sperone la volonté
vraiment majeur de faire en sorte qu'il
y ait au niveau africain
un mécanisme de coordination
scientifique qui soit
au niveau et de s'appuyer non seulement
sur les instituts pasteur mais ils
constituent surtout les outils
scientifiques qui existent en afrique
pour créer ce réseau c'est tout à fait
indispensable d'ailleurs je fais
remarquer que inde et malheureusement la
première victime médical de la pandémie
en france a été un médecin africain qui
étaient venus rendre service à compiègne
en médecins malgaches et qui des
épidémiologistes et qui étaient de
grande qualité qui malheureusement est
décédé du gros navires us en venant nous
aider ça montre que les scientifiques
africains peuvent venir aider les
médecins français lorsque nous sommes
confrontés à la gravité d'une situation
comme celle que nous connaissons sur les
travailleurs frontaliers et la
coopération avec l'allemagne
ce n'est pas la première fois on évoque
ce sujet
j'essayerai d'en reparler avec montre
légalement pour l'avenir je sais que
c'est difficile que la période actuelle
est compliquée pour les travailleurs qu
on appelle souvent les des salariés
populaire mais j'ai interdit à plusieurs
reprises pour essayer de faire en sorte
qu' on puisse alléger ses contraintes
j'ai bien adoré votre message je vais
faire au mieux et je peux pas à cet
instant vous dire davantage sur eux
monsieur poniatowski heureusement je
suis plus optimiste que vous je suis
conscient comme vous dd ans 10,4 et des
contraintes des nations unies du fait
que son fonctionnement aboutissent à ce
que le droit de veto puisse bloquer et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
créé cette alliance pour le
multilatéralisme c'est une force qu'il
faut essayer de pousser à des
modifications de comportement à
l'intérieur et des nations unies je
garde le principe
suivants messieurs poniatowski après la
dernière guerre mondiale
la communauté internationale s'est dotée
d'outils majeurs qui ont tenu au moins
jusqu'à maintenant avec divers succès
mais au moins avec un travail entre les
états qui étaient très positifs dans
différents domaines sans doute va t'en
passer à une autre étape
après cette autre crise on dit qu'à
cette crise a autant d'ampleur que la
grande crise de la guerre mondiale oui
sans doute mais si on pouvait à partir
de cette crise recomposé notre
multilatéralisme elle en tirer une leçon
ce serait peut-être une bonne idée en
tout cas moi j'ai cet optimisme là il en
faut quand même toujours pour essayer de
renverser les contraintes ou le fait que
les grandes puissances entraîne un
immobilisme du fonctionnement
multilatérale je termine en disant que
sur madame thériault analyse sur sur
haïti je sais qu il ya d une situation
un peu compliquée dont vous m'avez déjà
parlé merci de me le rappeler et on va
essayer de faire en sorte de les régler
mais une situation très douloureuse et
on a été amené à suspendre les adoptions
en cours pour des raisons de sécurité
dégradé vous mettez le doigt sur ce
drame que l'on connaît à haïti sur le
liban c'est monsieur bériault sur le jeu
j ai fait allusion tout à l'heure en
dans mon propos introductif
nous sommes inquiets de la situation
mais nous ne pouvons pas nous substituer
aux autorités libanaises il ya un
gouvernement qui a été constituée sur la
base d'un projet de retard probable de
réforme prochaine de réformes
c'est le point de passage au
liger pour redonner de la confiance aux
acteurs internationaux à l'égard du
liban le liban se prennent en main et
poursuivre ses réformes en particulier
dans le domaine de de l'électricité dans
le domaine de gouvernance la régulation
des secteurs plaidant la fonctionnement
de la banque centrale tout cela
nécessite beaucoup de transparence et
une lutte contre la corruption qui soit
extrêmement vigilante
j'ajoute par ailleurs le liban a fait
défaut sur sa dette
après une décision du gouvernement
libanais il ya un mois donc il ya
urgence pour que ce pays assure sa aux
prises en main certes il ya aussi une
crise année dernier au cob vous copie de
19 années jusqu'à présent limité
heureusement ils 632 gaza seulement même
pèsent sur l'économie seco nos systèmes
de santé libanais je serais tenté de
dire faisons tous en sorte que les
libanais prennent les décisions qu'il
convient de prendre pour qu'il retrouve
la confiance de beaucoup d'acteurs que
nous avions réuni ici à paris dans le
cadre du mouvement international sur le
liban et de soutien au liban et que nous
étions prêts se réunira au mois de
décembre dernier nous étions près tous
ceux qui étaient là tous les acteurs qui
veulent que le liban on retrouve une
dynamique une sérénité qui lui manque
que nous tous ces acteurs là était prêt
à agir
nous attendons que le liban john est le
point de départ les prennent les mesures
nécessaires
la période peut être opportune pour cela
voilà si vous vous posez les uns et les
autres pour que ce cette évolution soit
positive et bien ce sera une bonne chose
parce que nous sommes très attachés les
uns et les autres au liban
je vois là je crois monsieur le
président j'ai répondu à tout le monde
tout à fait merci merci infiniment
monsieur le ministre pour ses réponses
très précises
semblent tous nos collègues je vous
signale au passage une question qui ne
vous a pas être qu'il n'a pas pu vous
est posée et qui vise les résidents en
les résidents algériens et marocains en
france qui n'arrive pas à être rapatriés
dans leur pays d'origine car il semble
que leur titre de séjour soit bloqué
durera peut-être là aussi une action à
mener auprès des ambassadeurs ou des
gouvernements en question monsieur le
ministre merci infiniment
encore une fois pour vous même pour
votre équipe
je au passage remercier particulièrement
baptiste prud'homme qui a vraiment qui
est vraiment très attentif à toutes les
sollicitations des parlementaires et qui
fait un travail toujours joyeux
sympathique et surtout très efficace
je vous libère en vous remerciant nous
aurons peut-être l'occasion dans les
semaines qui viennent en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation de vous
retrouver je vous salue donc et je vais
garder nos collègues parce que j'ai
quelques indications à leurs données sur
la suite des festivités merci monsieur
le ministre et merci à nos collègues un
journaliste qui auront eu aussi beaucoup
de l'information par votre intermédiaire
c'est l audition de ministre des
affaires étrangères français jean yves
le drian
il a défendu le rôle de l'om est-ce
l'organisation mondiale de la santé dans
cette crise sanitaire mondiale
et puis concernant les relations
diplomatiques tendues entre la france et
la chine
jean yves le drian a assuré que
l'incident était clos
le ministre français se mobilisent
actuellement pour obtenir un cessez le
feu mondiale dans des zones de conflit
comme en syrie au yémen et en ukraine
et puis concernant à l'afrique la france
va débloquer
milliards d'euros pour développer des
projets sanitaires
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi si vous souhaitez
voir toutes les auditions du sénat sur
le corner virus vous pouvez aller sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur public sénat
[Musique]